Kobe Bryant was honored by little Wayne
at the 2020 Beatty Awards on Sunday I'm
just lost for words amazing the rapper
paid tribute to the late NBA legend who
along with his daughter Gianna and seven
others died in a january helicopter
crash
[Music]
videos a black mambas legendary career
as a Los Angeles Laker played as little
Wayne performed his 2009 song Kobe
Bryant the massive Lakers fan also gave
a shout-out to GG Vanessa and the rest
of the Bryant family goes out to Vanessa
and the whole black mother family this
isn't the first time little Wayne has
remembered his friend in January the
rapper released his album funeral 24
seconds of silence at the end of track
eight called bean James a nod to both of
the numbers
Kobe rocked during his legendary 20 year
NBA career in a March interview on MTV's
fresh out live little Wayne praised Kobe
as someone who strived to be the best in
everything about his legacy training
simpler I think the main thing for me is
without but I admire the most is how
would a heady ball he became a champion
he became a champion it is very hard to
become a champion not to mention either
and then again
[Music]